[Music]
the stock is about starting from scratch
in the world word ladies everything
basically if you're a startup didn't
have a even have a useful data sense how
do you go about it so very quickly
two words about me a highly machine
learning things that is tremendous of
known and unknown names we're like 20
people to give you an idea of how big we
are and what we do is we shouldn't
intelligence poor factory line as you
can see we have this box that sits on
the factory floor takes pictures of
things that are produced and we have
like a amp available everywhere to
analyze things that we like the data we
captured on the line so mostly it's
gonna be about likes to our domain which
is heavily image processing and using
like Lauren AI and machine learning and
deep learning techniques based on images
but I think a lot of those lessons kind
of apply wider than that just does to me
so let's dig into it so let's say you
want to make in the ice startup right
and then one of the first key questions
that you ask yourself where do you get
the data to build your models and easily
big companies like the Facebook's and
Google's and apples of the world have a
lot of data and like a lot of resources
of this juice and fuel right that you
need to build a useful model and as we
all know 3d is often not the algorithm
or not the you know and then they can
how many GPUs you have but the quality
of data that kind of powers the end
result so what chance do you have as a
as a dated against this Goliath of data
and this talk is mostly what can you do
where do you have an advantage so some
good news is not all data is equally
useful and a lot of times in practice
it's all about high quality realistic
label data sets and so the reason is
good news right if you just look at
first two high quality and realistic you
realize that a lot of that
which is the Google or Facebook or Apple
could have suddenly disappears or
significant notes away it's not enough
to have a huge pile of all kind of
images from the internet for a
particular use case you need high
quality and things that are applicable
to it and just getting an out of the
pile and finding representative images
is harder so here like the chances are
apart suddenly like much more equalized
still how do you go about dating dating
your own data let's talk about some
options so first maybe you can find
something from a public data set from
image Matt saw or a Coco or later and
will be is time for the opie group has
some of there's many many many others a
typical problem with those is there are
common and they're generic and it's hard
to find enough of a specialized domain
so you're doing like a healthy or like
us manufacturing there's not a lot of
public data from the factory lines out
there this is a highly coveted protected
information that you can just google for
maybe you can get your own dataset and
label it for some for some domains that
work for a lot of the things again like
healthcare and manufacturing you can't
just walk in into a factory you can't
even buy this data sometimes in some of
the means you can partner like for
example in healthcare people are able to
partner with hospitals and some other
networks to get the initial and useful
data set but say for us we can't just
walk in and ask Apple to sell us their
data right now this is not what they do
they have this mode of operation
similarly Foxconn or big contract
manufacturers of the world this is not
and there's different solutions this is
like one of those I can even jump start
this what would our kind of stake on the
ground here is useful data sets are
collected because people pay you to give
you data not the other way around and
the way Google is and Facebook acquired
massive thing a sense it's not because
they bought it it's not like wait they
invested them gathering it they just
receive
nature of working their product well to
make this example complete here's our
first product our first product is
mostly made out of Legos and it's just a
bunch of and plastic box some Lego and a
camera on top of it which you can
install on the factory floor the camera
will take a picture will upload to the
cloud and show it to you know listen
learning no AI nothing the question is
why would anyone buy this right why
would anyone pay us money to do this it
turns out that if you're building
something in China any the only way to
see what's going on there what's like
going on on the factory floor is to
travel to China go to the factory and
see what's going on and this is what
everyone does when they build build
anything and much more so when you do
your local development of life and you
even with this just the fact that you
can get those high quality images from
like from a well calibrated camera
without having to travel is a huge
advantage this means for a lot of the
issues you're trying to find the issue
and resolve it goes from weeks to days
and sometimes hours and our first
customers just have this product you
couldn't charge much for it but still
this is a way to get highly highly
realistic controlled data set that you
can play with okay so now you got some
data let's focus on the label portion of
the data sets as most of the more Algren
needs some kind of labels in order to be
successful so first stage is usually at
this point like F completely this anyone
often see posts like myths about machine
learning or data science and their feet
I see them a lot and one of them is
constantly there is that more data is
more insights that machine learning only
can play big data and you need blind
date on the train and all of them are
happily busting this myth and they're
absolutely correct the kinks about
transfer learning and augmentation are
really really really powerful or I think
a lot of you know what
but like transfer learning is the way to
have a generic model and then fine tune
it for your specific application and
have been tation is the way to
synthesize data from our small data set
to kind of artificially amplify your
training set at least initial space they
work beautifully and the typical numbers
is you can start with like hundreds to
thousands of image images and train the
model that someone useful it's not going
to be the best model in the world but it
could be something that is useful in
practice here's here's the main reason
why we have all when green papers we
have this expectation of human level
performance that is on this graph those
graph you probably can't read them but
this is like the typical graph if you
only see about like imagenet
classification error going down over the
years or a speech recognition here and
the red line is human performance and
every like every one that has been you
take it with a grain of salt like this
red line of this case with just one
person who like did this or like the
months and stuff like this but this is
what we think the human performance is
some human that's attentive knows what
the task is and the EMA specialist so
the reality looks like this right it's
someone in the factory they have five to
ten seconds to perform inspections and
they need to inspect all of this final
things and much more than this so full
time for or the holding current spike
inspecting and it have five seconds
burns inspection you can imagine that at
the end of it or even in the middle of
it it's the human operator that performs
a spectrum is very tired it's not like
it's a high paying job so what you're
comparing in practice is not the best
possible swimming performance and it
opens up the ability to produce a model
that has usable result next one is you
can find use cases that are impractical
to do with humans and machines are much
better at the first teacher that we
launched the three uses machine learning
the so called anomaly detection you can
select any region on any of the
images of the unions that you produce
this is a region on the left and across
hundreds and thousands and tens of
thousands of unit that you produce we
find things that are deviating there are
anomalies in manufacturing there is
never good anomalies anomaly always
means something bad and if you have like
a vague theory of what could be wrong
it's really a matter of drawing the
region on waiting couple of seconds to
see this result it's totally impractical
to a place humans to this task right
it's impractical to ask a human to
review those thousands of images and
this model is worse than what the human
would do if you ask them to do it but
just the sheer availability and how
quickly this the explorations of enables
people like deliver a very much useful
value so if you figured out some feature
some model you can train that creates a
first feedback loop which is with a
better product you can sell in people
more willing to give you data right so
this is you start accumulating data at
some point you need to figure out how to
label that sceeto scalable previously
you labels like hundreds anyway you can
do this in any way one person could do
this in like spare time so the easy part
level easy openness is if labeling does
not require special knowledge and it's
kind of clear what the definitions are
in this case there's a bunch of services
that you can use to do the scalp right
and Chirk crowds fly or nominals both
degrade hire someone from up org and
things like this let's talk about levels
heart pork
lately it requires expert opinion
experts are specialists and they never
agree with each other which is a typical
tease for us but in order to tell what's
going on this has to be as Hardware
expert understanding what exactly is
wrong with the unit some extra money so
you have an expert because the only
person who could deliver judgment on
this and the game is how do you identify
their output so one thing that turns out
it works you can pair an expert with a
bunch of non experts and do this things
together sit in the in the room in the
room next to each other while they're
performing the task and the basically
there's some training going on in
and the job of non-experts is to look
through images and whenever this is
something that's really a little bit in
a tiny bit deviating dance to expert for
opinion and slowly in time they are like
more confident in their choices but it's
crucial for them to to be close to each
other and this is a way to amplify your
experts maybe two to three acts because
the experts is your bottle and then you
need a product all for synchronizing the
expert opinion between each other for us
and our scale what work best is it's
okay for them to consult and to talk
about what what are what do different
things they see mean and maybe they're
missing something but for every
particular defect or a class probably
and more generically theirs has an owner
that determines the severity ranges like
what does it mean to be a show stopper
issue versus just interesting versus
somewhere in the middle so those
definitions
evolve over time but in every class has
an expert single expert owner that
tracks and updates those two finishes so
this gives you the ability to amplify
your labeling into our hands percolate 2
to 3 X the more powerful one is use your
machine learning models to accelerate
lately remember we have the feature
about finding anomalies we heavily use
it for labeling so you can see that this
is actual screens rather more interface
on top are the most anomalous issues and
then as you go down into less and less
than dollars and you can see on top
there's interesting things happening you
need to label but as you go down it's
more of like scrolling through pages and
just making sure that nothing is going
on and this way you can label extremely
efficiently so you basically spend a lot
of time on the top then less and less as
you go down and in the end you're like
okay everything that is in playful is a
no defect ethnography but feedback loop
here right with a better model sorting
is better so you can label faster faster
and faster finally last but not least
cookies are essential and I don't need
this in a figurative sense actual
cookies right so when you perform
labeling having some short treats
certain scientists when you complete the
Union award to thank is not does not
imply you like amplify the speed but
this is your retention mechanism the
benchmark is very simple experts in your
company tell each other that you have
good treats when you label data like
work towards that this is the actual
cookies so with all of those
optimizations we get to something like
two point five two key labels per person
per hour and human team is like 5k per
expert this is significant all right so
this means for to label millions of
images with four experts you need like
50 hours right so finally the the final
form of this is labeling happening a
part of the product I'll go quickly over
this but basically come up with the
features that has used the product you
label we have a feature where you can
perform monitor and will you will be
setting this up you can provide us
feedback which we use as labels and
incorporating training another example
of this Fox will have something that's
instrumental in Dropbox scanner which is
a little thing in draw possibly to scan
documents has a feature about adjusting
the corners if it didn't detect them
well naturally this provides a perfect
training data for extremely realistic
cases small percentage of people will
adjust but this gives you a data to
train a next iteration of model that
predicts pretty better this is the
extremely powerful feedback loop is
basically release I try to make that
like a recipe how to make the best model
for anything the more people use it use
it the better it becomes the product is
more useful more people start using it
is like a very powerful feedback okay so
this is almost all I had in a quick
recap you start with the some proxy
product to get your data to get you in
the game start with a small lake of
small and coke labeling to your first
model then launching the Scoville
pipeline and finally shoot for the
product that produces human judgment as
part of the
and we're somewhere here on this line
and yeah guess I've had this obligatory
slide about that we're fighting the only
thing I wanted to mention is we have
positions in machine learning and don't
require any ml background and that we
actually have those labels and
relateable did them build
infrastructures now it's like the
perfect time to come waltz in and and do
cool mission learning models and okay
now it's like every company has this
like time when it's like right for doing
cool stuff and I know how long this will
take
hopefully for some time so I usually
people mean by like supervised learning
is this big term right that has
everywhere in the spectrum and I think
in one way that people use it I think
it's very applicable to our situation is
typically you have much more unlabeled
data than labeled right so you have like
millions of images that are just sitting
there and small number that you've got
through all of this pipeline so methods
that are able to use both and their
certain some of them out there or the
way the whole talk is not too technical
if you're like interest to them and
another technical partner words but
they're I need to look very promising
interesting methods to combine the both
and it's yeah so which algorithm do you
guys are mainly using production to
classify images
did you CNN this kind of thing right yes
so so there's there's different there's
different settings for us so yeah we use
we used applauding and some pieces on
the traditional computer vision and
pre-processing but there are two very
separate tasks one is detecting specific
defects on the line and another one is
this anomaly detection or defect
discovery right and sighting there is
you have no idea what could happen right
like any any kind of deviations is
possible I need to find the ones that
are like meaningful and semantic and
even humans who do this don't have like
oftentimes are surprised at what date
what think they find yes they talk about
this intermediate stage of hiring or
paying experts and they're struggling to
Joseph said if a really poor model is
actually not too bad and you can
bootstrap crap evolve because humans
aren't that great at these things so do
you have you ever done a with data where
you could skip that intermediate
actually take people able and just go
all the way to end product mention like
drop magazine product is less very
sparse data are very infrequent but very
high quality have you ever seen it
possible to really bootstrap without I
think when you're just starting a
company it's hard to it's hard to skip
it because in order to get kind of the
adoption you need to go beyond your
proxy product and to something that it's
actually does useful because this is
usually the promise I think if you have
one use case from the product starting
up for other use cases there's an
opportunity to skip this intermediate
stage because usually the thing that you
can collect for example the images from
from factories you can imagine using
them for making other things and many
other products so I think like once you
got past the first hurdle the next one
is only easier from that and you can
start taking shortcuts
you